يعني بالتاكيد الوقت لا يزال خلينا نقول
مبكرا انا قد تصلوني اخبار الان من الريف
من سوريا انه عدد القتلى اصبح هناك 99
قتيلا والثلاث مئه جريحه هذا في الشمال
السوري من تحت الالقاب ينتشلوا 99 الى
الان قتيلا وتقريبا 300 جريح ومصاب في هذه
الاثناء بالتاكيد استاذه نادين المفاجاه
هي كبيره وكبيره جدا يعني الناس حقيقه لو
انه حدث في ساعات الفجر الاولى يعني خلينا
نقول وتفاجات العالم يعني والبشر المجتمع
بهذه العزه وهبط الى الشارع حقيقه ولم
يتسنى لنا ان نجمع الكثير او المزيد من
الاخبار طيب استاذ فايز هل عينتم زلزالا
بهذا الحجم في العقد الاخير ربما من
حياتكم وهل مره على غازي عنتاب وهذه
المناطق بالتحديد زلزال بهذا الحجم وربما
تتذكرون تفاصيله
انا الان عمري خمسين عاما وعيت اكثر من
زلزال طبعا في عنتاب هذا هو الزلزال
الثالث الذي
يصيب مدينه عنتاب خلال شهر واحد